wildfire season is now underway here in
nevada as well we all need to be extra
cautious with the drought conditions
we're experiencing mary jane belliesa
reports on how local and state are
working together to prevent wildfires
and what you can do as well
with warmer weather on the way combined
with dry conditions there's a concern
for wildfires we talked to officials at
the mount charleston fire protection
district fire chief jorge gonzalez says
his team is always on high alert and
ready to spring into action they conduct
annual wildfire trainings and closely
monitor weather conditions year-round
for any recent changes anything that is
quick to catch on fire means it can
spread easily and fast for many years
wildfire season has always been sometime
around may
to october time frame and around this
part of the country but as everybody's
experience in the western united states
and the drought conditions have pushed
those limits or those time frames even
further now we're having fires during
the wintertime and springtime or in the
fall for now officials hope the upcoming
monsoon season will bring rain and much
needed moisture to the valley in the
meantime prevention is key chief
gonzales says area firefighters work
closely with mount charleston homeowners
to mitigate fire spread fire chief
gonzales says he wants to remind the
community and visitors of our fire
restrictions on campgrounds and public
lands to reduce wildfire spread mayor
jean valeeza live local now